the Republican candidates making the
Biden economy a prime target during the
second debate but Tom surrogate and
California governor Gavin Newsom says
the president has a great record to run
on
I know I'm the spin guy and I know I'm a
Democrat but Biden one because they
identified problems but identified
Solutions and strategies that are just
underway bipartisan infrastructure at
chips and science act work we're doing
on climate that actually makes us more
competitive with China I thought it was
a good night for buying you do you feel
like Biden's holding you back from
running because no
are you kidding I'm enthusiastically
passionate about promoting The Binding
not only agenda but the great
implementation which is his second term
and having his back character decency
and I'm an old-fashioned guy I believe
in a little loyalty
Americans might feel otherwise about
that more headlines piling up that the
economy is not in as great a shape as
team Biden would want you to believe for
example Costco selling out of gold bars
people usually buy gold as a hedge
against inflation I'm not doing an
infomercial uh California's housing
crisis by the way getting so bad that
people are actually renting out these
tiny four feet by four feet sleeping
pods for 900 bucks a month
um judge at the same time that that
Gavin tells us he is enthusiastically
passionate about promoting the president
but what else could he say at this point
well you know I I have to tell you he
could say a lot of things he doesn't
have to say that I hate it when I get up
and lie look 77 percent of the American
people don't think that Joe Biden can be
effective in the next four years and
he's over there saying how fabulous he's
going to be but you know maybe he ought
to worry about the fact that amid
California's ongoing housing crisis
people are now buying these small homes
or these little pods that be or or
they're living in tents they're homeless
and this guys over here dancing around
about how great Joe Biden is he ought to
take care of his own State because
there's no question he's going to be
running for for president just a
question of when but it's almost as
though code violations don't matter in
California you got a tent pitch it you
want to sleep on the street pitch it you
want to get a pod one of those pods go
ahead but if you live in a nice area of
California and you need a uh you need a
brick wall or something on your property
you want to put a light above it they're
going to they're going to find you in a
code violation it's crazy what's being
allowed well they have these housing
problems but Jessica reports are that
between April of 2020 and summer of 2022
California had a net loss of 500 000
people that doesn't sound like a place
that people want to stay and it messed
up the budget it's a huge problem and
he's spoken about it he's spoken about
the homelessness problem but he's not
running for president he's now a Biden
surrogate and he's out there doing it
and he does a very good job from a lot
of Republicans you see Sean Hannity
interviewing him genuinely enjoying him
and we'll see Gavin Newsom V Governor
DeSantis in November I know but Newsom
had a pretty good line about that too
like this guy is not serious eye on the
prize man why are you debating a guy who
isn't running for president but maybe he
thinks he's looking 10 steps ahead that
this guy is going to end up on the
ticket I don't know if you're going
Gavin Newsom whatever you think of his
politics we can all admit he's pretty
slick and you have DeSantis up there
trying to smile you know that like weird
like thing he does it's not going to be
a good comparison so the numbers do
support the Biden economic record in
terms of the strongest recovery in the
G7 the unemployment rate millions of
jobs created the ax he's got if you
pretend covet never happened come on
but can I just say this is what's
important yes here actually there have
been 31
contested special elections that have
occurred in 2023 and Democrats have won
25 of them that is a tremendous
performance the same as in the midterms
so don't count us out because there are
people in tiny pods okay well we don't
know how they're gonna vote we do know
that the polls show us Fox and Beyond
everywhere that people do not believe in
their real life I mean David axelrod's
talking about this too like if you're
still paying all this money for gas and
for food the reality is you don't feel
better and and our polling and all the
others out there show that people
believe that the Biden policies are
actually hurting them you could talk
about data but Jesse it's true also to
say there's been a net downward revision
on every jobs number this year so if
you're telling people this great data
and they're like oh it doesn't translate
into my real life maybe the data is not
so accurate and maybe their perception
is more tied to reality you can say jobs
G7
and Newsome can cite windmills and chips
and infrastructure but that doesn't grow
people's checking accounts and people's
checking accounts Jessica are getting
slaughtered you don't have enough money
you can't buy a house you can't afford
rent
gas prices are going back up this winter
is going to be cold oil is going over a
hundred dollars
gas is probably going up over four
dollars you got student loans because
these universities are preying on people
no one has any money people are losing
money stock market's not that great this
is a disaster for the Democrats and they
can't hide from it doesn't matter if he
says jobs schmobs it's not about that
it's about money and people have less of
it they can't afford this lifestyle in
this year Greg how many gold bars do you
have well I'm just doing the math here
900 bucks a month for rent on a pod I
could stack 10 of them I have a backyard
Upstate if I got 10 there that's 9 000
bucks a month yeah well that's not bad
coming with you though what would Gus
come in with you though well no he
doesn't get anything you know what the
thing is if Joe only cared about
Americans the way he cared about his own
financial status we'd be in great shape
we under Joe Biden we went from America
first to me first me being Joe he
doesn't care about prices he doesn't
have to if we only hired Hunter to make
it rain for the average American we'd
all be rich and probably have Coke
problems
speak for yourself okay up next
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now